this project is called the burning
boards and it's a performance piece what
would inspire me you know starting with
a quote from Martin Heidegger which says
the possible ranks higher than the
actual 22 people's play they interpret
what other one might be thinking and
they anticipate the possible and there's
infinite amount of possibilities
happening and then when they make a move
it flattens out into one choice in a
myriad of possibilities becomes one
actual decision
this event has been performed only twice
before the first time at the Whitman
Whitney Museum of Art in New York City
as part of their biennial and then at
the Orange County Museum in Southern
California when the performance begins
they start to melt the different speeds
based on things like the wind the air
conditioning people's breathing you know
the formation on the board and the the
two players have to collaborate to
remember what pieces are which because
it's very possible that your queen might
melt shorter than a rook and you have to
remember which one it is and in that way
a conflict could also result in
collaboration
this piece was so perfect to be here in
the middle of one of the greatest chess
communities and in the country the chess
community that I've seen come together
time and again here the chess club and
in st. Louis I was surprised by how much
the grandmaster seemed to like it I
don't think that this is gonna be turned
into a professional sport but yeah I
really enjoyed it
you
you